I think there has to be some glimmer of
humor in it even if it's a character
that you don't actually that doesn't do
good things that is a bad person or a
sad person or a negative kind of person
there has to be a glimmer of a soul in
there otherwise it's just no interest
there has to be some connection with the
character of a sort of personal link to
something that you can kind of hook in
to the work I did for Clementine
Churchill was totally different from
anything I never done before
because I've always avoided hard work by
choosing roles that haven't you know not
doing historical figures for example if
you're doing a historical figure then
you're in trouble there's very little
footage of her but what there is you see
somebody who's really really nervous and
I thought that was really endearing to
be married the man who was actually
saving the world and to be so jittery
around other people I found that really
touching she was never allowed to
develop or she was never given the tools
to develop her brain and her intellect
and she had to do it all by herself and
she kept up really really well and that
I found really I found that really
admirable I tend to kind of try and find
out the essentials and then imagine
nowadays there's no rehearsal I was very
rare to have rehearsal and I'm a bit of
a pedants and a bore so I go off and ask
people to run lines and do things like
that and people look at me a bit
sideways when I ask to do that but I
just like having a crack tip before and
and hearing the other person's voice
because sometimes you get on the set and
you were introduced to some unbelievably
famous actor who you're a little bit in
awe of or frightened of or whatever and
then you've got to just sort of just do
it so I prefer to you know have a
cracked it before so at least I get used
to the sound of his or her voice you
know and there's nothing better than
working with an actor who can surprise
you all the time and and that you know
you can trust so you know he's not going
to put you in a position where you can't
get out of it he's gonna work with you
but he's not he's it's not going to be
anything you've ever imagined before
that it's very
which is the case with Gary obviously
but it's not very positive what I'm
going to say but but I think I think you
just have to learn to be really really
to not take it take it
all personally whether that be success
or failure or rejection or you know
audience going head over heels about you
you just got to keep it all in one place
in a very safe box because the rejection
doesn't get any better
you know after 30 years of doing this
job if somebody says no you can't have
that job ah it's awful me what's wrong
with me and you know it's it hasn't got
any better since I was 20 you know it's
the same and the success is thrilling
and but actually I am better at enjoying
the success but knowing that it's I can
keep it in the box but I can enjoy it in
the box yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]